ich sage bei uns in diesem Land fehlt
die Sensibilität gerade wenn es um
cyberkrange geht und auch im Kontext des
Ukraine Krieges tatsächlich und das ist
auch das was ich vorhin meinte wir sind
schon lange Partei weil auf dieser Ebene
natürlich auch in Deutschland
eindeutig ist Chile gibt und ich glaube
auch in der aktuellen Situation Krieg
Inflation höhere Armut steigt die Gefahr
dass in dem Bereich Internetkriminalität
immer mehr passieren wird und ich glaube
da haben wir ein zu wenig offenes Ohr
und zu wenig offene Augen tatsächlich
die waren ja selbst cyberkrimineller
wenn man das so nennen kann
was haben sie genau selbst verbrochen
ich habe einen Marktplatz geleitet
zusammen mit zwei Mittätern in Darknet
[Musik]
es technisch ich erkläre das immer gerne
technisch technisch kann man das mit
E-Mail vergleichen nur das keine
Elektrogeräte gehandelt wurden sondern
Drogen und die waren die technischen
Vermittler sozusagen ja und wir wurden
2019 verhaftet ganz kurz wurden auch
verurteilt wir sind alle aktuell noch
draußen
und warten jetzt auf die Entscheidung
vom BGH und ich habe mich natürlich
nach der Verurteilung nach der Festnahme
sehr intensiv auch gerade mit den mit
der Thematik Cybercrime beschäftigt man
reflektiert was macht man da man kommt
auch mit Tätern ins Gespräch und auch
mit Opfern wenn ihr ein kmues Denken
Mittelständler fast jeder wurde schon
Opfer beraten wenn man selbst mal Täter
war ich glaube ja tatsächlich weil man
einen anderen Blickwinkel hat also ich
vergleiche das immer gerne mit mit einem
Trainer oder Strategie beim Fußball der
weiß natürlich theoretisch über die
Flanke schießt
aber er wird sich nicht so gut schießen
können wie ein Spieler und das ist eben
der Unterschied und ich glaube schon
und das ist ja auch mein Appell ich
glaube um Cybercrime kämpfen zu können
ist das Verstehen und man muss auch
verstehen wollen ich habe das Gefühl
hier in Deutschland bei Privathaushalten
genauso wie bei Firmen ist es irgendwie
gefühlt so dass wir jeden Tag mit Medien
umgehen mit IT-Systemen
und wir lassen die Türen auf also Fragen
stellen
und alle Türen sind offen keiner zu
Hause so ist so gefühlt der Umgang wenn
man an seinem Security denkt Deutschland
lahmlegen
weiß ich nicht also ich kann ein
Beispiel nennen
vor gar nicht allzu langer Zeit wurde
die Universität in Düsseldorf glaube ich
Opfer eines Kitas Angriffs und es war
auch im Kontext ich meine es war
Düsseldorf
corona-zeiten Düsseldorf hat
Lernplattform bereitgestellt für
600 Schulen ungefähr im Bundesland es
gab ein Videos Angriff 600 Schulen waren
betroffen und das heißt die Schüler
konnten nicht lernen und dahinter ist
ein 14-jähriger Junge
wurde festgenommen und ermittelt und
was da eigentlich peinlich muss man
wirklich sagen es gibt viele weitere
vergleichbare sechsjährige sehr
intelligent 14 Jahre
tatsächlich
es gibt weitere Fälle wenn man ein
Rockstar Games denkt da gab es ein viele
die die GTA spielen werden das wissen da
gab es League uber wurde gehackt der
Täter war 17 Jahre alt
und das kann natürlich was im
persönlichen Bereich was man selber
immer macht ohne darüber nachzudenken
ich denke zum Beispiel ein
Online-Überweisungen wenn du darüber
sprechen denke ich so bin ich da
vielleicht etwas zu nachlässig ich
glaube es fängt schon viel vorher an und
das ja das Problem man kann ja natürlich
kann man überlegen ich stelle mir
it-sicherheitsberater ein machen viele
Firmen nicht weil zu teuer ist später
willst du dann teuer wenn es eine Menge
Attacke gibt aber das fängt ja viel
vorher an nämlich bei Menschen ja also
oft ist die Schwachstelle natürlich der
Mensch es gibt eine fishing E-Mail es
gibt einen Anhang jemand macht unbedacht
etwas auf und so werden dann komplet
Systeme verschlüsselt Krankenhäuser hat
mir in Deutschland auch schon
das Krankenhäuser
Opfer einer Salbeitee wurden und dann
auch tatsächlich die Ambulanzen nicht
mehr gelaufen sind
würde ich gerne mal Herr Schindler
Fragen ist denn dem der
Bundesnachrichtendienst weil man jetzt
daran blickt an ihre Zeit da ist der den
gut genug vorbereitet auf
Cyberkriminalität
also besser geht immer das ist klar und
gerade im Bereich IT glaube ich haben
alle Nachholbedarf jedenfalls diejenigen
Behörden die mit der cybersicherheit
befasst sind wir haben in Deutschland
große Probleme da stimme ich ihm zu wir
haben große Probleme einmal die
richtigen Leute zu finden die das
überhaupt in den Behörden machen können
weil die Behörden viel zu schlechter für
bezahlen und es ist schade dass er seine
Energie so gebraucht hat anstatt
beispielsweise beim
Bundesnachrichtendienst zu arbeiten wo
er bezahlt ist ja noch alles mögliche
hätte machen können also uns fehlen die
die richtigen Leute uns fehlen aber auch
die richtigen Eingriffsbefugnisse nur
zwei Beispiele also wenn beispielsweise
eine Firma eine Institution angegriffen
wird können wir heute nur zuschauen wir
sehen ah da kommt eine E-Mail und die
legt ihr den ganzen Laden lahm mehr
können wir nicht machen wir können das
System abschalten und können gucken dass
wir die E-Mail umleiten aber wir können
nicht beispielsweise im Sinne eines
heckbags zurückschicken
auf den Server nach Malaysia und sagen
so jetzt machen wir die mal kaputt damit
der nicht mehr diese E-Mail schickt
dieses heckback ist in Deutschland
beispielsweise verboten das dürfen die
Behörden nicht die Schweiz macht das
schon seit 2016 erfolgreich niemand hat
der Schweiz den Krieger erklärt alles
okay und so haben wir beispielsweise
demonstrans Datenschutz in Deutschland
die beispielsweise eine
Vorratsdatenspeicherung verhindert wo
wir solche Marktplätze die er geleitet
hat beispielsweise viel besser aufklären
könnten die entsprechenden Kunden viel
besser rückwärts beispielsweise
erfassen könnten und es geht nicht nur
um Drogen sondern es geht auch um
Kinderpornografie und viele andere Dinge
und ich glaube da haben wir alle einen
großen Namen also ich verstehe wo sie
hin wollen
Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ja so ein
riesen Thema ich glaube tatsächlich dass
man in diesem Bereich mit
Vorratsdatenspeicherung
so gut wie gar nichts mehr reicht weil
Peter so wie ich auch wissen natürlich
wie sie sich anonymisieren das Tor des
Werk an sich gefasst ja richtig
natürlich ich glaube tatsächlich auch
dass das
Strafverfolgungsbehörden durchaus
Möglichkeiten haben und besser geworden
sind es fehlt aber glaube ich an Geld an
Aufklärung und an Manpower wenn aber ein
Marktplatz oder ein kriminelles Netzwerk
groß genug wird und da tatsächlich auch
genug Manpower und Energie reingesteckt
wird dann bin ich schon davon überzeugt
dass deutsche Behörden bkas bitte auch
oft international ermittelt so was auch
bei uns das ist da Möglichkeiten gibt
jeder zu identifizierende
Vorratsdatenspeicherung hilft da aber
nicht sondern mehr Geld und Spezialisten
wenn es um IT-Sicherheit geht und
Cybercrime weil um das nochmal
auszuführen natürlich ist es so eine
Vorratsdatenspeicherung jemand der jetzt
sage ich mal unbedingt
in erwischt man vielleicht so in den
Taschen die den den den selber zu den
Taschendieb aber wirklich kriminelle
Menschen die Organ jetzt im
Internetkriminalität world Gruppen das
was wir gemacht haben Fischer die
Kreditkarten klauen die wissen natürlich
wenn man sich anonymisiert und da hilft
eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht
Besucher von
kinderpornografieplattformen erwischen
sie mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung alle
so ja aber ich rede hier von also von
wirklich auch von Rente Attacken das ist
ein riesen Thema in Deutschland also
fast jedes Unternehmen wurde schon Opfer
und da kommen sie mit und oder auch was
wir gemacht haben da kommen sie mit
Vorratsspeicherung halt nicht sehr weit
und ich denke auch ne ich finde man muss
das machen auf jeden Fall und die Täter
sollen identifiziert werden so wie auch
wir und da muss auch da müssen auch
Straßen her ich finde aber
dieses Thema mit also ich bin wirklich
immer noch ein Freund von Datenschutz
und von Privatsphäre und ich habe auch
so ein bisschen das Gefühl
tolles Werk zum Beispiel Darknet ist ja
sehr negativ behaftet Anonymität wird
ganz oft mit kinderkidlich gesetzt und
das ist nicht so
Felgentreu wie ist denn die Politik
darauf vorbereitet also wenn man das
jetzt hört kriegt man ja schon etwas
Angst und Schrecken na sobald ich weiß
es hat sie gerade zum Thema
Vorratsdatenspeicherung doch ein Urteil
gegeben auf europäischer Ebene das macht
jetzt der Koalition Kopfzerbrechen die
SPD war da eher auf der Linie von Herrn
Schindler die beiden anderen
Koalitionspartner sind da eher etwas
zurückhaltender aber was ich da jetzt
als Lösungen abzeichnet kann ich Ihnen
nicht sagen da bin ich bin kein
Innenpolitiker mehr deswegen bin ich da
nicht in den Details drin aber im Grunde
meine ich schon dass wir da mehr tun
müssen und ich kann ihnen auch aus
militärischer Sicht sagen es ist ja die
Bundeswehr hat ja praktisch als als
fünften Bereich des militärischen einen
Bereich für Cyber defence aufgebaut also
um wirklich Angriffe
im cyberraum auf Deutschland abwehren zu
können und das ist wichtig das muss
unbedingt gemacht werden aber da sind
wir das ist eigentlich auch immer noch
in den Kinderschuhen die Amerikaner auch
die Briten sind da deutlich weiter als
wir und auch das ist wieder natürlich
eine Geldfrage eine Frage des nur aus
und der Manpower da sollte man
erhebliche weitere Anstrengungen
Erfolgen aus meiner Sicht und dann gibt
es dieses Problem dass Sie angesprochen
haben mit der Frage wie wird man sich
eigentlich also eine militärische Logik
geht ja immer auch davon aus dass man in
der Lage ist einen Angreifer
abzuschrecken so und das ist bisher im
Bereich Cyber Defense kaum vorgesehen
das Cyber defence sieht im Moment
bildlich gesprochen so aus wir bauen
eine möglichst hohe möglichst
unübersteigbare feste Mauer und die
Angriffe prallen auf diese Mauer und
prallen von dieser Mauer ab aber wir tun
nichts um Menschen von Angriffen auf
diese Mauer abzuhalten und das ist auf
Dauer nach meiner nach meiner naiven
Verständnis vielleicht können sie da was
zu sagen ein zum Scheitern verurteilt
weil irgendwann findet einer einen Weg
durch diese